now India is attempting to track down
people who attended a gathering of
Muslim religious leaders after 24 of
them tested positive as many as 1500
people from across India as well as from
other countries were at the meeting in
the capital New Delhi 700 had now been
sent into quarantine while hundreds more
are in hospital let's talk to our
correspondent now Elizabeth puranam
who's in New Delhi Elizabeth how was
this this meeting able to take place
under the conditions imposed by the
government which are among the strictest
in the world
so Martina was allowed to take place
because it actually began on March 13
before the lockdown and even before the
curfew was in place so it was a two-day
congregation of Islamic preachers as you
say from India and around the world but
after the congregation it ended a lot of
people you know we think around 1,500 at
least decided to stay on at the mosques
accommodation and by the time Prime
Minister Modi announced that there was a
nationwide curfew over a week ago on
Sunday two days before he announced the
lockdown he also announced that all the
buses and trains and services had to
stop and these people say that there was
no way for them to get get back to where
they're from
after that stranding them there and
we've since had as well as those numbers
that you mention of 302 taken to
hospitals 700 put in quarantine six
Indonesians who attended the gathering
have since died my team in the southern
state of Telangana which they traveled
to after the gathering and we've also
had one cleric and Srinagar and indeed
administered Kashmir pass away that was
last week and people related to him have
tested positive for coronavirus so there
is a lot of concern around this mosque
which is very much being seen as a
hotspot authorities in Delhi have are
now converting a 60 thousand seat sports
stadium into a quarantine facility
really expecting the number of cases to
go up right Elizabeth
what is the situation more generally
around the country so martín there are
over 1,100 cases around the country now
on something like 32 deaths the big
story here though over the last week of
the world's biggest lockdown has really
been the big tragedy that the lockdown
has the lockdown has created for India's
poor and millions of migrant workers in
India there is something like 120
million people in India who work in
different states to where they're from
and we've seen hundreds of thousands of
them walking hundreds of kilometres to
have returned to where they're from
after losing their jobs no longer being
able to pay rent and as I said earlier
you know all bus and train services have
been canceled and in the last few days
we've heard local media human rights
groups saying something like at least 22
people have died making these journeys
because of starvation because of
dehydration or being hit by trucks while
walking on highways so that's the
situation we've had the government to
clamp down even harder on people
crossing state borders and some state
governments have had to set up
quarantine facilities where people are
traveling to make sure that their stay
because there's a real concern that all
these people moving from the cities to
rural areas could be carrying the virus
the virus with them right okay it is
both puranam live in New Delhi thank you